so anomaly detection is identifying
unexpected items in your data set that's
different from the norm sometimes we
call anomaly detection as an
outlier and we live in these pandemic
times and
we live in these weird times that you
know we usually meet
uh you know
locally or we meet at an event now it's
all virtual so that's
in a way an outlier
so the assumptions are for an anomaly
detection
is anomalies only occur very rarely in
your data
and their features differ from normal
instances significantly
and you'll we'll talk more about these
uh as we go through their presentation
so what are the causes of outliers it's
either
artificial or non-natural and of course
the other ways
natural artificial
causes could be data and errors and this
is very common
you know 100 000 versus 1 million that
extra zero makes a whole lot of
difference
measurement errors and also another one
where you know we're talking about how
we measure things
maybe inches and you know metric system
versus english system so that that's can
cause
outliers experimental errors when you
start collecting your data at the late
at the sprint
instead of collecting all through uh in
intentional outliers this is kind of
like asking on
you know uh high school students if they
under you know under reporting of
alcohol consumption that might be a good
example of an
intentional outlier a data processing
error when we extract
etl when you extract from one data
source to another data source as you
transfer it sometimes there might some
communication errors or the way we we
transfer the data
might have some errors sampling errors
also
where you kind of identify in this case
the height of all athletes
you know it's a report about height of
all athletes and
but you only included mostly basketball
players that would skew
your data and that might be a sampling
error of course natural errors
i mean it's not one of the artificial
ones that
matter crosstalk occurs in in nature
so what we're trying to do here is you
have your stream of data or you have
your input data you're passing through
this gate right is it an anomaly anomaly
data anonymous data or not
and sometimes of course you know you
won't be able to detect all of them
so you think about the blank ones here
are good data and one
ones that it says defective or defective
data sometimes you would detect them
most of the time maybe but sometimes you
may might miss them
so it can happen
but as much as possible we want to
improve our algorithms
to be able to do this
one good saying about anomaly detection
is
you know it's kind of like finding a
needle in a haystack if the needle is
that big
it definitely can find it but if it's if
it rarely occurs it
you know sometimes it's harder it's a
harder problem to solve
so different methods and how you would
uh
do uh anomaly detection it could be a
rule-based system
statistic you might want to do
statistical techniques
or you can use machine learning
rule-based systems most likely you've
done this and you've worked on it if
you're a developer
is when you specify the rules or assign
a certain thresholds or
limit to your data to identify
you know what's out of whack right the
the problem with rule-based system or
disadvantage of using a rule-based
system
is you know you need experts of the
industry
to detect what is you know what is
common problem and what's
you know what's the normal anomalies the
known anomalies
and of course you know the pattern does
not
does not change or does not adapt you
know as your data changes
and it it won't adapt especially when
you have seasonal data
and you know it might require some data
labeling you have to require an industry
expert to look at your data set
and to identify and then you can you can
specify the rules in your program
another way is through statistical
techniques
statistical techniques would be
something like uh
you know you calculate the median mode
or you can
you know use your rolling averages or
moving averages if you're
stock investor you see those graphs and
they have those
uh sometimes they use statistical
techniques and when to buy
when to sell and you're trying to get
out of the norm you have to kind of
identify hey this stock is going to shut
up those kind of things and that kind of
gives you a statistical technique
algorithm for sensors for iot data
sometimes you might
be working with uh you know what they
call common filters
so the sensor information is giving you
a lot of noise
and to kind of give you a low-pass
filter to
to identify which of the data sets are
going to be thrown and which one is
going to be passed through
your system of course you know there's a
lot more
the advantage of statistical techniques
would that it's easy to interpret i mean
someone can calculate
uh the the media and their mode or some
statistical
property and sometimes it's more useful
than machine learning methods so if
you're
if you can put it in a formula that you
can you can identify
all these anomalies then it might make
sense to use statistical techniques
of course for machine learning method
there might be way there might be
capabilities where you you might you can
do it as a supervised learning
identify you know hot dog not hot dog
that type of
uh you know where you would use decision
tree
uh you know and
also another way is unsupervised
learning
uh unsupervised learning is when you're
kind of looking at
uh being able to to kind of
you know they talk about k means or
clustering and those kind of things
and of course there's a self-supervised
but you would use
uh an auto encoder
to do this okay
one of the things you have to consider
uh if you're gonna do
you know anomaly dissection versus
supervised learning which
you know because both of them you're
trying to identify
uh which is anomalous or not in
supervised learning
you're also looking at it in terms of
you know being able to identify
uh through classification uh so if it's
anomaly
anomaly detection techniques you would
use if you have a very small number of
positive examples
and a large number of negative examples
and there are different types of and you
know sometimes it's harder to learn
from positive examples maybe you have
not discovered some of the
anomalies yet so there are some anomaly
detection techniques that might help you
uh as compared to a classification or
supervised learning
supervised learning is good if you have
a large number of positive
and negative examples that kind of equal
them you know with your data set
where it's enough positive example for
uh for the algorithm to learn
and of course the positive examples is
kind of like the same as your training
data set so that's kind of makes a
difference in how you would decide
uh how you would you would uh use a
anomaly detection versus supervised
learning
so anomaly section would be something
like fraud detection you know
most likely if you experience it with if
you have a credit card and suddenly the
credit card doesn't work
because it's out of the area where you
usually buy
that's you know fraud detection that
they're kind of looking into the banks
are looking into
manufacturing if you have a machine that
you know
going through its process and some
sometimes it's
being able to to identify if the machine
is getting some errors and
that might be an anomaly data they use
this for data centers
also identifying you know which servers
are
failing so it would be a good capability
or
looking at the logs i've seen uh you
know those
observability tools lately that have
incorporating anomaly detection in their
in their systems and of course the
internet of things would be a good
example
where you would need anomaly detection
supervised learning would be more of an
you know you would use it for email spam
classification
or a weather prediction the reason why
you would kind of have
do email spam classification because
there's a lot of examples up there
as you know you can identify cancer
classification because there's
experts that already know what they're
looking for so it makes sense to have it
as a supervised learning algorithm
compared to
to anomaly detection
so machine learning sometimes you might
do
uh density based anomaly detection uh
sometimes it's clustering based
you know where anything outside of that
cluster
that's considered anomalies you know so
this is normal data
and this is outside data or you know
anomalous data so sometimes it's uh
nearest neighbor or sometimes it's
clustering
sometimes it's gaussian you you you know
there's that distribution
that you would calculate and anything
outside of that
gaussian distribution it can be
considered anomalous
so they're you know and sometimes it's
support vector machines where you kind
of split your data into two you
split you know your data set so is it in
this area that means it's normal
anything outside of that line
it's anomalous those kind of things so
there's what i'm trying to get at here
i'm going deeper into other different
techniques and how you would do anomaly
detection there's a lot of algorithms
out there that you can use
to be able to to do this
uh one of i would like to kind of
do a little demo on where you can
do anomaly detection the simplest one
that i found
is using the stat analysis there's
a node package manager called
uh it's called this stats analysis so
you do npm install
right now guys i'm just showing this to
you using python notebooks because it's
just easier to
to kind of explain and rerun my code as
we go
and so but either way it's running uh
this python notebook is
actually running a typescript kernel so
it can run javascript application in the
background
so in this case you know i do requires
that analysis i have a series of data
and we know the last data is you know an
outlier or an anomaly
so what there's this program that would
just say okay just
you know take out the outliers out here
in this data set and then it will return
you the all the ones that are in its
range
and it's based from of course you know
looking at all the series of data
and figuring out that's what is outside
of it so that's the simplest example i
can show that's running in javascript
let's move forward
all right internet of things of course
it's my favorite topic
you know it happens because you know
sensors are getting cheaper
there's more volume that we're
collecting you know you think about your
phone
there's a lot of data that's being
collected from your phone collecting
your homes and all that because
the sensors are getting cheaper and of
course data speed sending it up to the
network or the machines
are getting better processing these
that's that's why internet of things is
here but the thing is
there's some you know so there are some
things
that you know as we explore
expand the capabilities of our iot data
the data is you know it's moving fast
but whenever when something goes wrong
it's frustrates the user or it's it's
frustrating to use you think about you
know my
you know google tv i have at home and i
sometimes it yeah if i can't use it it's
just frustrating if i can't use my
uh you know my google home and those
kind of things or
google voice or something some of those
things right
and if when it's broken it feels
something like this
trying to fight where in my pipeline
that that's broken
and so and it gets frustrating
and it's hard to find and that's where
i'm kind of talking about where
you know internet of uh
anomaly detection it might be useful for
uh for these type of uh
application and more and more i've seen
uses of javascript or notebots or
however you would call
this javascript application that
actually connects to your
to your internet of things device
so time series anomaly types there are
different types of
uh anomaly time series when i talk about
time series that means you have
you know component of time in each
each version or each
each item on your on your list is
you know the values i'll show more so
you think about this right
uh you have your time
component and then the value around that
time component
so you think about it's your temperature
at your home a certain temperature
and then suddenly it spiked up and then
it spiked down
and then it went back you know the
normal
you know and this is an outlier
so that's
another way is uh spike and level shift
where it's suddenly you know it's
running this way and then suddenly it
went up most likely your ac is down
that's why the temperature your home is
suddenly higher those kind of things or
like these kind of where you have the
patterns
certain patterns of your data and then
and then it suddenly changes the levels
that's spike and double shift another
one is pattern change so you think about
the flow of water
and then suddenly you know most likely
if you're
you know gardening and you have your
hose and then suddenly someone stepped
on the
hose and then the water that's spouting
and spitting out and
is is less that's there's a pattern
change right there
your data set of course seasonality
you know we all know certain times of
the year that sales are up
you know ice cream sales are up or pizza
sales are up
ice cream sales are up is higher during
the summer pizza sales is during
what you call this football season or
you know the
super bowl that's what
typically happens so there's seasonality
in your data that you have to consider
so if you're
doing anomaly detection you have to to
think about
that uh seasonality
and of course you know i did talk about
production issues and you have
production issues
especially if you're streaming data you
know you're going to
find it's kind of like a stopping a
train
and when we talk about uh you know time
series data you'll hear more about this
iid data set
identically distributed and independent
identically distributed
that means the distribution does not
fluctuate it came from the same
probability distribution so if you look
at this roulette
it came from the same source right
it's the same roulette that you're
picking your data
another one is independent that means
you throw the ball and you throw it
again and throw again in each round and
you
you measure so if you think about the
temperature in your house the data
that when you grab the temperature is
not based from the previous data set
it's all you know getting the sensor
data really
reading the sensor data and then you're
adding it to your to your list
or you're adding it to your database you
read your sensor data again you head
into your database they're independent
from each other
all right and of course when you do
anomaly section in time series data
you have to to figure out if it's a
univariate
versus multivariate univariate that
means there's only one variable that
you're tracking
so in this case if you're looking at
sales data
and you're figuring out you know like in
this case
this is your sales data went down and
then went up and this
can be anomalous not so that's just one
univariate multivariate is you have
multiple variables that you trick
that you're you're tracking like in this
case there's vibration
temperature pressure velocity of
of your data set and you're trying to
identify from that
area is this you know based from those
variables all at the same time at that
period of time
you know is it anomalous or not so
that's when you have to consider when
you
you have to look at multiple variables
versus one variable
time series anomaly detection you know
in this case we're looking at
spikes and change points spikes
is temporary burst change points is when
you know know typically we talk about
level changes and trends
that you're trying to detect all right
so just to kind of visualize what we're
talking about
uh i think about it this way so i have
this
device that let's say this is a
machine that you're detecting uh
anomalies
and you know it runs back and forth it
stops after a while runs back and forth
and this anomaly detector is looking at
the historical data from here to here
to identify if that last item is
anomalous or not
in this case it was detected hey there
that is an anomaly it's expecting it's
supposed to be around this
area but there is a sudden dip so that
that means
that is anomaly should you send a an
alert
or you should you know and it's up to
you to do it to
figure out what what causes that anomaly
but at least it it becomes obvious uh
once you uh you figure that out
once it's it's reading that streaming
set of data
okay a one one of the easiest way
on how we can we can do anomaly
detection
is using azure cognitive services
uh it's a ai for every developer
without machine learning expertise in
azure cognitive services
there's different types you can talk
about speech vision
web search language it's just an api
call
as a developer it just makes it easier
for us to integrate
anomaly detection in our application in
one of the
one of the example one of the items that
they have
as part of anomaly detection azure
cognitive services
is this anomaly detector there's also
personalizer this is more
uh for personalized experiences there's
also content
moderator to uh to kind of
you know figure out what's the content
but this we're going to today we're
going to talk about anomaly
detector so anomaly detector is a
restful api
that can detect abnormalities with your
data
it can identify what is the best fitting
model without training
you know pre-training it identify the
boundaries of the anomaly section you
can
and it does not the good thing about
this it does not need
labeled trading data and you can still
fight
fine tune and it's really production
ready because a lot of the microsoft
product teams are already using it
integrating it to their
application and
it i think it's amazing uh one of the
things that are currently in preview
is a multivariate anomaly detection that
means you can
you can do multiple variables now
so uh you can detect anomalies
as a batch or you can do it real time
uh and of course you know you can get
more information about your data
because and i'll do more demos about
this sometimes it
makes it better that way so what's
happening in the back end is uh once you
send your data it tries to
extract the features and identify what
algorithm it can use
right if your data set has seasonality
in it you might use some
list of this algorithm certain
algorithms if it
does not doesn't have seasonality it all
automatically knows and then it would
use either course or
granularity and there's like different
algorithms that they're currently using
if you ask me i don't know how to
implement each one of these so it's
you know about my periods more more
advanced that i can
that i can understand all these
different algorithms that they
do but it allows us as a developer to
quickly integrate it to our application
so let's do a quick demo on how we would
we would do this all right
let's go back here let's do something
simple
uh the simplest one so in this package
jason there's
multiple dependencies uh right now the
anomaly detector has these uh
javascript you know package that npm
package that you can use into your
application
azure ai anomaly detector detector
that you can integrate so in this case
we'll we'll look at the uni
variant if we have time we'll look at
the
multi period
but i think i'm going to focus on this
since we only have about 15 minutes or
less about our presentation so we'll
focus on this
um this uh
sense hat so what i have here i have
these
a raspberry pi actually by the way this
um
python notebook is actually running on
this device
if you haven't heard about raspberry pi
it can run node it has an operating
system it has linux operating system
in it and of course it's not a it's not
a 386 it's an arm processor
the good thing about this you know
there's there's uh they call it this
sense hat the sense hat has these you
know rgb
colors and has temperature sensors all
these sensors that's on top of my
raspberry pi right now
so that might might make it easier for
us to be able to uh
to read some of sensor data so
you run a few things here so like in
this case i want to run
i'm using this tslab if you're not
familiar with tslab that's the one that
allows me to have
to have this python notebook running
or this jupyter notebook having a ts
lab kernel or typescript kernel in the
backend
so in order for me to be able to read
sensor data
for this sense hack device there is this
node
sense hat npm package that can control
my led device so let me show you what
i'm talking about here
so if i run it
it clears my data set so
so this allows me to read some of the
sensor data
and if i want to read imu data so
meaning
i want to read some the acceleration the
gyroscope that is on that
on this device i can use it to to give
me the value
of these you know it also gives me the
temperature the pressure and humidity in
the room
so that's you know there's so many
simple commands that you can
you can do it has some libraries that
how you can you can run it
okay
now on this one i want to collect
time series data you need two things in
order to collect the time series data
a timestamp and a value and i want to
put it on this
array of entries right
and this what this one does is it would
read
the temperature data okay and
but uh anomaly detector requires me to
specify
what is my granularity with my data if i
submit it to the api
in this case uh the the minimum that
that it
that it requires me is the every minute
so every minute
set of data you can do hourly or weekly
you know if you think about sales data
it could be
yearly annual data or it could be
monthly data
in this case i want to get you know
every minute
data and i want to round it up to the
nearest minute
because for some reason it needs it
requires me to do something like that so
uh i already run this a few minutes ago
or this morning uh see it rounded up
you know to the nearest minute and give
me the value of my temperature
around that time and then of course you
know i do a set interval i want to do it
every minute
for the next 15 minutes
right i want to run this uh you know set
in turbo for the next 15 minutes collect
me some data
and of course after i run that you know
because you know it's kind of like any
cooking show
yeah i already pre-collected some of the
data for you uh
so you know i started around this time
and then this time
this is what we're gonna submit to
anomaly detector to identify if there
are anomalies in our
data set
okay so once i have that data
of course i i use the anomaly detector
package to be able to talk to my to the
api
um of course some of the credentials
in order to to call the api there's two
things that you would need
you need uh api key and endpoint in
order to generate the api key and
endpoint you need to go
you know use azure cli if you go to
azure
you have to spin up a new version of
anomaly detector
or you know anomaly detector that's the
case
okay so so once we do that
we can call the anomaly detector client
okay and then
we're passing in the endpoint it will
give me the url where to connect and the
key
in order to connect to that endpoint and
once we have that
we can call using detect last point
meaning the left you know
looking at the last item on my uh
on my list is the last item
sorry about this error for some reason
it's giving me
a different kind of error but at least i
can show you these
so we specify hey every minute every
minute
i want to be able to
send the points the series of points and
then detect
is the last item on my list uh
anomalous or not so once i called the
api
it would give me something like this you
know in this case false it would return
false
if the last point you know this case the
last point
is anomalous or not
and it's the same way as um
so in this case yeah the last item on my
list is not
an anomaly so we were talking about this
and based from the data that you sent
previously or you know as a
and then in this case what i want to do
let me try to reload this real quick so
that it would
see if we can get that error out
of course you know it's live demo so
that's one of the reasons why
it wouldn't show sometimes it might have
some errors
but the good thing about this is at
least i can give you some of the results
after you know when i run it before
so in this case okay
give me some errors
okay let me see if i can i'd also ran
this
same example earlier in the day
so just in case i i wanted to show you
what the results are
so my data set is like this and
what i wanted to do right going back
to this since somehow the browser didn't
show up properly
so i have my items and i want the last
item i want to force
it to become anomaly so
since i wanted to force to become an
anomaly i kind of
add an item to it meaning you know
i set the time and that the last value i
change the time
and then i change you know i add 100 to
to my item list and then
and then in this case i set the pixel
if and then of course in this case
i want you know sending this data set
again right with the last item
being instead of 39 degrees
maybe i send it as 139 i send it
up to the api and then based on that
if it detected as anomaly
it would set the pixel meaning the
the my
raspberry pi it would set it to i don't
know if you can see that x
here it would send it would send it uh
to a different color and to say hey that
last data
is anomalous and then it would give me
that error
let me see if i can rerun it again just
kind of attempt to see if i can
if it will show up sometimes it would
see if we can run the last item on our
list here
so give us some errors might be some
network problems
of course let's see if i can open that
up
okay go to the last time on my list i'm
going to run this one
but before i run it i wanted to make
sure
hopefully it will run
we'll see what happens
the last item on my list if
it's if there's an anomaly or not
hopefully it will
it will show i don't know if you can see
that my lights are
it's because of my window it's kind of
harder to see but it turned into
x that means the last item on our list
it was detected as
anomalous uh row 15
and and then of course it showed that
hey
there there is an anomaly there and it
send an alert
to my device all right i got two minutes
left
my presentation that's that's close
isn't that cool i don't know what just
happened right we collected some data
from our you know using javascript we
collected some data
from our raspberry pi
be able to call the api
and it tells us hey the last item on my
list is
anomaly anomalous and we are able to
control
uh our our sensors here and send the
alert
that's the idea about it so where can
you use anomaly detector
of course there's c-sharp javascript and
python bindings so if you want to
do a library so that if you want to call
the api it makes it easy for developers
you can also integrate it inside the
docker container
so if you're if you're going through
kubernetes you can
you can do anomaly detector inside
kubernetes or
inside your docker compose
power bi you can actually integrate this
through your power bi
and azure data breaks also you can
integrate that
if you're looking at streaming data
one thing that's new uh i'm not going to
be able to demo this but
you you'll get the idea that's also part
of azure cognitive services
is a metrics advisor but you think about
it this way right
you have all these database or data
sources
that you can collect and then you can
detect anomalies and through this
sas platform you would consider maybe a
a sas platform and then based on that
you can send alert
and then identify later on what's the
root cause of that alert
so it's it's a platform where you can
you can do this it looks something like
this
where you have all these different
graphs you know that's connected to your
data and
as you go identifying which ones are
anomalous or not
based on that data once it sends alert
it kind of gives you that capability
of being able to you know you have this
incident hub
you can send that alerts and then you do
your investigations
uh based from based on this like in this
case
you know it's your multivariables multi
uh
types if you think about this in this
case it's looking at revenue or cost
data that it would send alert if it
suddenly there's a dip in your car a dip
in your revenue or
a spike in your in your cost those kind
of things so that's what it's geared for
so the other day the best super power
that you can give to your project
is what we call a spidey sense or
anomaly detection
and if you're interested in
downloading or about the slides and
about my
information about this presentation uh
you can there's a qr code here
or you can go to my github account and
be
able to download these
python notebooks to verifying the view
or
be able to run it locally
about myself my name is ron dagdag i'm a
lead software engineer
and ai edge specialist at spacey
i'm a microsoft mvp the best place to
contact me is through twitter or
through email or go through my
connecting via linkedin linkedin is the
best way for me to connect
and if you're interested about my
personal projects
the dag.net and i appreciate you geeking
out with me
about spidey senses anomaly detection
about you know jupiter notebooks and
about raspberry pi
internet of things device and of course
about spider-man
and now that you got bitten off by this
spider feel free to experiment and try
out all these
different tools that i just talked about